salut tout le monde comment tu te sens
qu'est-ce que tu en penses de lime
comment tu te sens pas trop stressé ou
non en fait animer c'est une école
spéciale par exemple il y a des outils
non
tu peux essayer ok bonjour C'est Yousri
pour brut
salut c'est Juliette et le jeune que
vous venez de voir c'est Yousri il a 19
ans depuis ses 11 ans il est en IME un
institut médico-ducatif en gros Annie et
me c'est un établissement spécialisé et
adapté pour les enfants en situation de
handicap mais le problème c'est qu'il y
en a pas suffisamment et pourtant comme
vous allez voir notre reportage saisie
ont une grande utilité pour les enfants
comme Yousri donc du coup voilà je fais
un visite de Nîmes allez on y va donc du
coup c'était cool
voilà ça c'est des conditionnements
voilà ça c'est le groupe des grands des
ados des ados 2 ça c'est le groupe des
ados 4 c'est à dire les grands on est
grand parce que à 20 ans on quitte l'IME
on travaille on va travailler
atelier technique par exemple blanchisse
conditionnement voilà
7e il accueille les enfants de 0 à 20
ans qui sont répartis dans différents
groupes selon leur capacités certains ne
feront encore un petit passage à l'IME
tandis que d'autres ils resteront
pendant toute leur enfance et toute leur
adolescence
faut que tu tires comme ça
non comme ça
Pauline on a besoin d'être s'il te plaît
j'ai réussi c'est bien merci
oups désolé
voilà qu'est-ce que tu en penses oui ça
va
c'est bon
ah ouais il faut remettre la terre
voilà
c'est bon j'ai fini
et tu sais pourquoi tu es donné
des difficultés
alors la première c'est Yosri et ben
bravo bravo vous avez bien joué
mais il y a trop de queue je veux
regarde
que du coup voilà il y a il y a le melon
et du pain aussi oh là là ça va rigoler
comment tu te sens comment tu te sens
[Musique]
la fin du mois de juillet et toi Erin tu
connais la ville du Maroc
[Musique]
Casa ou à la Rabat Tanger
Agadir
il y a pas la plage
alors je sais que je regarde arrondir à
l'euro près on était à 6,24 €
et à la fin de la semaine il compte sur
leur petit chou qu'ils ont gagné et ils
peuvent acheter quelque chose dans notre
boutique c'est pour motiver moi j'ai 4
euros 10
Pauline ça je vais économiser donc du
coup je garde l'argent pour la semaine
prochaine
on est dans la récré je vous demande
il suffit du bruit parce que les enfants
jouent au foot
qui revient
du coup je vais demander à Pauline
qu'est-ce que tu en penses de l'IME
c'est un endroit super chouette pour les
enfants parce que ils peuvent apprendre
tout ce dont ils ont besoin
à l'IME
des fois c'est difficile de trouver
ce dont les enfants ils ont besoin et de
répondre à ce qu'ils ont besoin des fois
on n'arrive pas à faire ce qu'il y
aurait qui serait bien de faire
pas forcément
on a du mal à trouver comment vous aider
ça c'est dur de trouver comment vous
aider des fois on arrive on a du mal
ouais d'accord
bon merci
les jeunes qui sont au septième ont tous
des handicaps différents et des besoins
différents en termes d'encadrement et de
soutien par exemple certains jeunes dans
l'IME ne parlent pas d'autres ont des
troubles du comportement et peuvent être
violents et d'autres comme yuseries sont
un peu plus autonome l'objectif de l'IME
c'est d'aider tous ces profils à
s'intégrer au mieux dans la société pour
Yousri cet objectif c'est de trouver un
travail en fait une blanchisserie c'est
c'est qu'on travaille avec les vêtements
par exemple on fait le repas ça je
pliage mettre la machine à laver mais
dans sèche-linge et aussi ici on peut
faire la lessive donc c'est pour vous
préparer préparer ce qu'on va faire plus
tard
ça c'est quoi comme on est où ici là
sont sales et du coup on les plie non on
en fait
on met au sale et après on met dans la
machine à laver en fait il est en train
de plier du linge sale ça va pas c'est
quoi la première étape
voilà
de rien
[Musique]
pourquoi pas parce que je préfère les
conditionnements une fois majeur des
jeunes comme illustrer peuvent notamment
travailler dans des établissements
spécialisés et adaptés pour personnes en
situation de handicap qui s'appelle des
ESAT donc voilà
moi je suis dans le conditionnement je
travaille
avec avec les petites boules boîtes mais
il nous faut 10
par exemple
[Musique]
Youtube c'est quoi ça
je pense que c'est YouTube
c'est un site on regarde des vidéos
il y en a un qui peut peut-être nous
faire un entraînement
qu'est-ce qu'il faut dire
bonjour avec le sourire on a besoin de
l'eau de la tombola on commence par dire
qu'on veut un voyage on va en voyage à
Barcelone parce que c'est nos projets
rêves donc
on a besoin de l'eau pour la on a besoin
de la tombola s'il vous plaît
merci
on se retrouve bonjour en fait on a des
projets parce qu'on va à Barcelone
est-ce que ce serait possible de
donner à un tombola s'il vous plaît lors
de la tombola s'il vous plaît
un projet sur Barcelone
et le but c'est de s'autofinancer et
donc en fait on organise une tombola ou
des
local
est-ce que ça a été très clair ou pas ce
que tu as dit
on avait compris dans l'ensemble
d'accord mais il faut que
tu d'accord quand vous êtes stressé vous
parlez parlé par les Parisiens
d'accord vaut mieux un petit peu plus
ok on continue
bonjour
en fait on est allié module on est libre
du bois donc par exemple
on est venu d'Ennery est-ce que on
organise un projet pour aller à
Barcelone est-ce que on voudrait un lot
de la tombola s'il vous plaît
du coup j'ai bien géré mais il a dit il
a pas l'eau de la tombola parce que il
parle pas bien pas bien français
il y a pas d'obligation
qu'elle n'est pas la patronne et aussi
j'ai autre chose à vous dire elle n'est
pas la patronne ah d'accord ok
c'est une cause spéciale
en situation de handicap
vous avez déjà appris un peu l'espagnol
ou pas trop non
on y va comme ça le grand saute
au Maroc ah et tu eh ben là il me l'a
offert
les éducateurs et les équipes de l'IME
font tout pour permettre à ces jeunes de
se sentir le plus à l'aise possible avec
le monde extérieur par exemple ce
jour-là Yousri part avec l'IME en
Belgique pour découvrir le musée de la
BD à Bruxelles
c'est pas grave on cherche tous nos
tu te concentres et tu racontes que tu
as envie de raconter
j'ai au TGV je pars à Bruxelles je suis
trop content parce que je suis jamais
allé à Bruxelles et là-bas on va visiter
le musée de la BD
gros bisous
voilà
vous êtes
tentant
moi je suis super content d'être au
musée de la BD alors Julia
tu es content d'aller au musée de la BD
ça fait pas trop stressé ou non
c'est bien ça
du coup voilà on est
on est dans la salle exposition regardez
les Schtroumpfs oh là là et je vous
montrais aussi regarder
c'est coucou dans Dragon Ball regardez
oh là là c'est c'est génial ça
et tu coupes ce que je vais faire je
vais demander au monsieur c'est des
comics à tout de suite
donc du coup c'est ce que ce que j'ai
acheté c'est des mangas c'est Dragon
Ball Dragon Ball super et Naruto Tom 43
et Tom 19 dans Dragon Ball voilà la
musique
est-ce que c'est du rap non c'est du
rock
ça
moi mon projet peut-être mais peut-être
mon projet
j'aimerais bien travailler à les autres
soyez amis 60 Hollande
invitez tout seul une colocation
j'aimerais bien le Japon
Maroc toutes les villes du Maroc
et dans le sud aussi
habiter voir en colocation avoir une
copine
[Musique]
et ça peut-être
moi j'aimerais bien
de plus en plus d'enfants en situation
de handicap sont orientés par le système
scolaire classique avec l'objectif
positif de les mélanger avec les autres
élèves mais c'est pas forcément adapté à
tous ces jeunes qui ont besoin d'un
encadrement spécialisé aujourd'hui il y
a un peu plus de 1300 ime en France et
pourtant ce n'est pas suffisant car les
listes d'attentes pour y entrer sont
super longues au moins 11000 enfants en
situation de handicap attendent toujours
une place
voilà
j'en ai terminé ça la vidéo s'aimait
bien ça m'a plu du coup je voulais dire
au revoir et en plus de niveau sur ma
chaîne il se passe des petits
commentaires un petit pouce bleu voilà
salut au revoir avant de continuation
bonus pour l'instant on a toujours pas
une chaîne Youtube
mais n'hésitez pas à m'envoyer un
message sur Instagram ou les réseaux
sociaux si vous avez d'autres idées de
sujets que vous aimeriez bien que
j'aborde à la prochaine
[Musique]